Mika's in dallas taxes hey Mike welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show better than I
deserve what's up well there won't take
so much of your time but so I know how
you hate credit cards so I had my credit
card with Bank for America right now and
well it's been closed for a while and
it's all about over 26,000 on it and
looks like now they're trying to I guess
suit me for the money now how long has
it been since I've made them I want to
say by the end of 2017 in a while so two
years yes sir okay yeah they're going to
show you yeah on 26,000 they're gonna do
that sure yeah how do you make this try
see what my options are what do you make
well me and my wife together about 130
okay why have you been unable to pay
them making a hundred and thirty
thousand just arrived just took place
and it kind of went to a snowball effect
and just kept adding up to the interest
and everything minimum payment was
almost like four hundred dollars just
for the minimum pay $100 is forty eight
hundred dollars a year you make one
hundred and thirty thousand why were you
unable to pay them that management bad
management
disorganized not paying attention and
you so you ran the car in the ditch is
that right
pretty much yes sir me too brother I did
that too except I did it with more zeros
than you did it so I know how you feel
so are you ready to straighten up your
whole life and use this credit card as
the reason to look at the whole thing
because you make enough to fix this mess
pretty quick so how much other debt have
you got everything that's do on your
cars totally a car supreme clear both
cars are free and clear what are they
worth
2010 Camry probably let maybe 10,000 I
guess that's the miles on it the other
one is a beat-up car okay all right so
where do you think if you were gonna
guess that all your money is going I
would say one day care and probably my
mortgage and student loans how much do
you have in student loan debt myself
seventy thousand my wife over a hundred
K uh-huh okay there we go
that makes starting to make some sense
alright so what we need to do is the two
of you you and your wife sit down and
say our life is full of stress and sucks
right now and we need to fix it are you
willing to do that yes you think she is
yes yes okay alright then we can walk
you right out of this alright because
two hundred thousand dollars changes
your life you make a hundred and thirty
so how long does it take to get two
hundred thousand well three years of
sixty thousand gets you pretty close
that would put you living on seventy
thousand not counting taxes you put any
money in your 401 K right now or else
we're gonna stop that we're gonna
completely focus on these debts we're
gonna get on a written budget and you're
not going out to eat again you're not
gonna see the inside of a restaurant
unless you work there you're not going
on vacation anymore you're broke and
getting sued by Bank of America
so it is time to straighten things up do
you agree with me yes okay if y'all are
willing to do that I'll show you exactly
how we have a class called Financial
Peace University it is nine weeks long
and we plug you into a one-year
membership a financial piece online
which has all of the audios videos
online plus the follow-up class legacy
journey plus the debiting are the
budgeting software budgeting app the
world's best called every dollar that it
connects to your bank it's every dollar
plus it's about six hundred dollars for
the stuff I'm giving you for free
because I have been where you are scared
and broke and I don't want you to be
there anymore but
you're gonna have to do a lot of hard
work in the next three years to become
debt-free no payments at all and I'm
going to show you how okay if I do that
will you go to the class yes all right
here's the good news in Texas they
cannot garnish your wages so all they're
gonna do is put a lien on everything and
a lien on your house they can't do that
in Texas homestead laws so that you're
living the perfect state to keep them
stiff-armed away from you you don't have
to panic about the lawsuit but you do
need to start paying them three or four
thousand dollars a month so that in ten
months this set is completely gone and
it goes away and it never bites you
again and then we'll start working on
the student loans so hold on Kelli I'll
pick up we're gonna get you signed up
for Financial Peace University and take
care of your brother you call me if you
need some more help I've been where you
are I know what it feels like to be
ashamed and scared